An important part of Android Wear
application design is that while
the watch is acting as a display
to push notifications to the user,
much of the work is
actually done on the phone.
Interware devices do not connect
to the internet directly and
instead, they typically communicate
with the outside world via the paired up
phone using Bluetooth or WiFi.
Another important thing to note is that
Android Wear applications are embedded
inside the regular phone
APK from Google Play.
The user will download the phone APK and
it will be installed to the phone.
The Android Wear companion app
that runs on the phone will then
detect an embedded wearable APK and copy
it over to the Android Wear device and
install it there, too.
Whenever the phone APK is
updated on the play store,
this process is repeated
to the Android-ware device.
The nice part about this is that
if someone is using your app, and
they're at an Android Wear device,
it will automatically
support it if it's available.
What this does mean is that you must
create an application that runs on
the phone because a wearable
app cannot exist without it.
Even if the phone app does nothing,
you still need to provide one
otherwise Google Play cannot process and
distribute your APK file.
Here are some other things that
are also important to know.
The phone APK and embedded wearable APK
must have the same package name and
version numbers.
The permissions requested
by the wearable APK
must also be requested by the phone APK,
as well.
The phone APKs and
wearable APKs both need to be
signed by the same developer keys.
If you get any of these things wrong,
the wearable app will fail to install,
so be careful here.